okay four people joining this livestream
we are looking at functionality planned
for 12.1 and this is in the calculus and
algebra area and great so by the way I'm
sorry somebody needs to be on mute who
isn't okay go ahead just to summarize so
we've been rolling out asymptotics as a
third gradually as a full third mode of
computing to numeric symbolic and
asymptotic yes okay
now the two there are three new
functions this time around and our
designed augmentation or changes for the
existing ones to be rolled out so
they're three new ones I'm scared about
one called just asymptotic that's the
that's the first one on this list it's
gonna be yeah
wait before we drill down can I just
yeah yeah so the design changes is in
the way that you give you know we've
looked ahead for multivariate versions
because for in most cases we don't have
multivariate versions of this but we
looked ahead even if we can't and
implement right now what the design
would be so we're not sort of cornered
arm and so on and what can I say there
are improvements to the existing one
over they'll continue to be improvements
so then then let's just drill into the
ones that are new okay so hold on I'm
just okay so
asymptotic product I understand that's
okay the one that I'm really so the
that that will do
apart from a sort of expressions is that
it can deal with operators effectively
so if there is an unavailing it
integrates Laplace transform
so we've elected not to design
asymptotic Laplace transform asymptotic
inverse Laplace transform asymptotic
Fourier transform asymptotic inverse
Fourier transform I don't know it's time
why this things unlike series which has
X comma 0 comma 5 right of that does
that too right so actually the point is
there the leading term is is very
important you know in many cases all you
can hope for is deleting term if it's
advanced enough hard enough getting a
leading term is it's just oh are we
gonna support this syntax for series as
well we have not changed the series at
this point but we could in which case
what you need to do is the same thing as
we've done here is that there is an
option that tells you how many terms
it's called asymptotic terms well I
understand I understand but but I think
that series I mean the difference here
with series obviously is with series and
I'm now confused because if I do this
I'm very confused here it's gonna be the
same right so the only thing the place
where it isn't gonna be the same if I
say ah like e to the 1 over X or
something okay and I do the same thing
with series e to the 1 over X ok I'm
totally confused what's the difference
it's not just that one of them is a
rewrite I mean no I'm
so actually asymptotic does make use of
series in a refined way and you start to
see that for some expressions
particularly when there are branch cuts
and so let me see it's no clients so
where
where doesn't start to differ because it
can handle
it you know I think that the key to me
tacky use case is that you can have
we need an asymptotic inverse Laplace
transform and every other integral
transform is summation transform yes so
where is that gonna happen most of it so
what about a series expansion for those
things I mean the way series works right
now the thing gets evaluated and then it
series of fives it afterwards is
asymptotic something that doesn't
evaluate its arguments no it does
evaluate its arguments so but so if I
put in here if I put in here something
like e to the at I don't know e to the x
squared or something there and it would
follow the evaluation order so in other
words what this jut if you had if you
had inactive mi integrates do an active
in to integrate should still work so I
get that okay so if I say inactive
integrate okay now if I do the same
thing if I did that with series e to the
x squared
no integrate okay so let's just know
that they integrate just evaluate so
it's I know I know I know it's not gonna
make a difference okay so then I say X 0
4 or something fine it does that okay
now this is probably going to get itself
all choked up right yeah okay but
although that could be supported yeah
Abby
a problem that the the fundamental
output structure that serious uses is
too limited no no this is not we're not
gonna do this we're not gonna have
another one of these we we put in
something new and then we can't explain
to anybody why they should use the new
thing versus the old as I said that a
killer application is that it's not the
expression case even though the vendor
will argue up and down that it's much
cleaner output than serious and all of
that I think that the killer use case
are the combinations of solvers in
active terms I know that's a different
use but which could perfectly well be
supported in series so let me understand
something else in series we have this
nice plus order whatever and series
automatically you know if I take that
series percent three and I take it to
the fifth power it will do the percent
three to the fifth power it will do the
right thing right what's the analog of
that it's Devendra here
amia yes yes yes okay so what's the
analog of that fast not exceed that
there isn't because that's relies on too
serious data structure to do that I
understand that but so what I'm saying
is I think that's a good feature and
you're blowing that feature up so if I
do it with a with a with something like
a you know a Laplace transform data
column we're guessing that that only
works for the class of power oriented
series it's very very tiny why because
the the M because the closure operations
are not there for general asymptotic
series yes it's a much wider class
Steven I mean do I know and buying okay
okay so give me some examples right so
you take an take an asymptotic off let's
see okay so as I'm taught of inverse
Laplace transform you know how do you do
that without having a much more general
kind of object I don't buy it I don't
buy that I'm sorry I just don't buy that
I mean look look at this case okay so
this case let's take a look at that case
with a series can we can we do a series
expansion around infinity yes again okay
so let's
what this is doing relative to that okay
you've only a one term actually were
there
so now that it only has a leading term
so what do you mean it only has a lazy
term well the point is that we may not
know the other terms in the series you
know you just have a leading asymptotic
which works now we could probably give a
message to that effect but I'm so what
are you talking about okay that they're
a result you specified a second-order
Devendra yes specified beyond leading
terms yes if we did one or the one you
should get back to what you want no I'm
not no I want to know why is this not
expanding it in successive tonight why
don't they stop because we only had
first of all they can't I mean so Steven
that's what I'm saying that there's
different orders of growth si si
yeah that can't be that can't be
expanded in and a full you know in X
powers can't express e to the e to the e
today I can't even read it yeah
minus e to the okay okay and it's the
same it can grow too slow for it for a
power kind of Sears if you have nested
logs it's too slow for power-oriented si
I understand all of that okay so but I'm
not getting okay so you know this order
concept I thought also worked for I mean
you know that it's not obvious to me why
that doesn't work perfectly well by
saying order e to the 1 over X or
something instead of just order x
squared or whatever because there's so
many scales available to you which one
I'm gonna pick
si yeah which one are you which scale
you're gonna pick there's lots of them
in the traditional discrete world and
series captures a few of them really
well but can't go beyond that without a
lot of for the work if you don't have
the user specified a scale okay there
would be a success rate that's probably
approaching zero yeah sorry sorry say
that again
okay an asymptotic series is is unique
if given the scale however as a
practical function you won't know what
scale you need to use to express the
solution in until you know the solution
yeah I understand the scale as so if we
if we delegate back to the
user to specify the scale no no I think
that the success rates gonna be totally
zero hopeless okay what I'm complaining
about okay look this is the fundamental
problem what you seem to be doing is
rewriting series to be better okay
except that you're dropping certain
features and that I'm not so so fine
you're not buying that because you want
this Auto evaluation of series and I'm
saying that we can do a bigger study and
I can demonstrate more clearly why it
can't be done okay fine oh yeah
lightweight version but it cannot in
general support to set the closure
operations that you can do for a power
series okay let's take a look let's take
a look at something like asymptotic
solve
okay so asymptotic solve has features I
assume that are offered goodness sake
the that I assume there's just simply
unn inaccessible to anything to do with
series is that a true statement or could
one imagine so
asymptotic solve first of all it needs a
sort of an interface that's specified
right to says you know how do you get
the input data that should be sold like
interface first of all right
but you could have and unev alyou ated
or an inactive asymptotic I mean you
could have an inactive solve or
something like that and in the principle
probably specified it I mean that's what
I mean by you have an inactive integrate
look for 30 years we've given people the
opportunity to think of power series and
to manipulate power series in the same
kind of way that they manipulate things
they can still manipulate power series
that way they just can't manipulate
general asymptotic series I understand
that I understand that I'm walking
through this I don't think it's it's
okay hold on okay we give them an
expectation that there's this thing that
okay I want to walk through it a little
bit more slowly okay okay so you know
we've got a nice
analogy going between number precision
and what happens in um you know in
series okay
now the fact is if you say what is the
limit of something you know all bets are
off you just got the limit if you say
even what is such and such an integral
what is the asymptotic value of such and
such an integral not the expansion but
just the asymptotic well I guess it's a
different I guess that's just a limit I
mean in a sense I'm just trying to
understand you know because what you're
delivering here asymptotic in this case
looks like a limit what's the difference
between this and the limit of this thing
I see because the limit is not X
parameter eyes by X right well I mean
the limit of something if you have an
asymptotic series is the same as first
of all if there's an asymptotic series
where the first term is a constant that
is the limit period yeah I understand
but in this case here well you've got a
more complicated scale you do have a
limit because e to the zero effectively
yeah but what asymptotic is doing is
it's giving you the expression okay I'm
just let me I'm a little slow here okay
so so in the case of a series you are
defining something which has some radius
of convergence or whatever else and it
is essentially an approximation to a
function right yes and and
approximation there's a degree of
approximation that is no one and one is
able to when one does operations on that
one can you know get the thing to the
right to the right level so to speak um
you
now there is a candidate output wrapper
that I would like to do but we didn't
have time to prototype and get it up and
running sufficiently which is which is
much less ambitious than what serious
data does which only applies for a very
important but still a tiny set the
Vasant otic scales which is to maintain
the partial order because these terms
are always ordered correctly in the
scale given and then what could typeset
it more nicely the downside is that you
can't immediately evaluate it to have
something happen you need to do normal
or something like that but it would
typeset nicely well what do we think is
good I mean in the case of a series you
know sometimes it's annoying you just
want us I mean the problem is do you
you know numerical value of a series I
don't even know what happens if you do
that I think it works right I mean if I
say series sine X X 0 10 or something
and then I say % / dot X arrow PI over
10 or something ha that's an interesting
problem ok so I have to do normal before
I do that I mean we could make this work
yes okay so all right I'm still trying
to understand this so
there's a trade-off right so what do you
typically do with the asymptotic output
like e to the 1 over X here
what would you typically do next to it
so hmm well I mean sometimes asymptotic
is used for understanding if you're
gonna say that this algorithm is of this
growth for instance yeah so it's a
terminal thing in that case but I know
it's a terminal you know it's not always
a terminal thing it's also an
approximation the asymptotics is used as
an approximation I understand in which
case you're going to numerically
evaluate it a lot to probably and use it
in place but so in the case of series
you know it's not uncommon to do serious
operations on the series like you want
to do you know you're trying to series
solution of an equation you want to you
know put in a series expansion for some
variable and then and then lets it
propagate right the propagation is
important just like it is from a
numerical evaluation but you're telling
me that for asymptotic evaluation
propagation is not so important because
it's not achievable and some for some
reason it's not possible I mean it's you
can't this thing that works for the
class of a puso serious yeah just
doesn't work for more general classes
because it because there isn't a
hierarchy of orders in the same way or
what their it's and you know things like
duplication is not even defined
necessarily can you explain that now I
can't give you a super good example I
would have to to drill down but this is
this is what happens that you get so the
black of closure operations is this is
this this hottie fields business or is
it something different yeah it includes
the hardy fields that's one thing of it
that's includes a lot of RT fields I see
so for example if I do is asymptotic
let's say I just say let's take a very
simple thing if I say asymptotic sine ax
X goes to infinity
I see so if I were to say it's just
gonna say this is this is a thing that's
that's the result then and if I say
comma you're gonna say that is a
fundamental result as in yeah I see so
now but if I put in inside there X over
X minus 1 for example
yeah because you're basically evaluating
it at one for exit infinity yeah okay so
I mean
this is a very funky creature so you're
telling me that the base expansion
thingies I mean like for a we say series
power series / so whatever you know the
base expansion oide thing is X to the P
where yeah actually it's it's not
general P it's it's it's it's rational
you know it's it's you know it's n over
Q I mean it's P over Q where those are
integers right well there's a nice
ordering of those kinds of things right
so you're not getting into some
undecidable is this is this particular
transcendental expression bigger than a
smaller than this one so on right um
okay but in this case what you're
telling me is there are these completely
non commensurate so this thing is a unit
in some sense in other words that is
different from them from this guy for
example right you're telling me that is
wild oh maybe it isn't so well because
that's just the expansion of X minus one
so I mean what you're saying is the
things that are should be considered as
non divisible non expandable Basie's
don't know what they're called I don't
know what those things are called the
things that are the the base of the
expansion so the scales scales okay so
they're a bunch of so then there's a
whole
bunch of sort of non commensurate scales
as what you're telling me is that right
I don't know if I can express if that's
correct way to say it okay I mean
commensurate I don't know that's the
right way there's something has to do
with rational numbers commensurate no I
understand but I mean
okay so let's walk through what it is
the features that asymptotic and I
why did you introduce asymptotic only
now I mean was it needed I mean it I
said the killer thing it should be able
to solve all the things that that if you
have an int and unavailing integral and
a none evaluated some and you have them
plus together they might lead the
cancellations if you're gonna get their
synthetic correct scale for the sum of
them you need individual solvers and you
need to possibly back propagate I mean
it but if I had an you know an N n sorry
a ddigon saw eigen dissolve mmm
would that also be supported here in
principle yes I'm not sure do it now but
yes okay okay so I've got a couple of
comments here so first of all is there
any good reason why we shouldn't support
inactive integrals and things inside
series I think that we probably should
not quite sure what in the long-term
consequences are of that seems it seems
like if we can do it you know you might
as well try to do it I mean in and no we
there may be plenty of things so now the
next question is okay so I've got two
questions about this that's one of them
is supporting unev Allen active
mathematical constructs and series the
other thing is when series is basically
pretty useless as in oops what my typing
and help did i just type that i just
mess up your sorry let me just erase
that um the when series fundamentally is
going to not do much I mean so if I say
series 1 over sine 1 over X X 0 4 or
something it's gonna do nothing right
it's just gonna leave it on whatever now
presumably if I say asymptotic of that
it will
also leave it unev a little bit it will
be prouder about it you see what I'm
saying
prouder well as in this one serious
Erised it can't do anything here right
here as some tonic is like great I'm
giving you the asymptotic result be
happy right okay so what I'm thinking is
there may be a way to dovetail is a bit
better by doing something in a case like
this have like generating a message that
basically says I'm not this isn't the
fully form thought but but as a way to
kind of get serious and asymptotic to
not look like they're in competition did
you see what I'm saying yeah so for
example generate a message saying no
series no pre so style series is
available giving asymptotic results or
something whatever the right thing is
you know I'm saying so that so you're
giving a clue that there's something
that's more in the asymptotic you know
bailiwick than the series one does that
make sense
right quite sure but well the whole
point Roger is we can't have functions
that look like they're dueling no I
Yeah right so so I think what we need to
do is series has been faking it for
decades pretending that it can do
serious expansions that it clearly can't
do like this one right and unlike for
example presumably if I do let's take a
look at what happens if I do Airy AI
around infinity okay now I'm just
totally confused I'm just totally
confused I mean okay
it did an okay job with that um and now
I do asymptotic okay now I am terminally
confused okay help me out here why is
the ordering different well they're both
kind of not I heal okay so first of all
that first object you see that has
nested series data objects in it
somewhere
yeah that's horrifying okay and but you
know where is there is a serious data
object the order locally within that if
you can identify where they are the
orders gonna be kind of natural now the
one that you see from asymptotic it
relies on plus ordering which is
slightly arbitrary for other reasons and
it may be good or it may not look I
think that even generating a message
here saying no puso series available
note no ordinary power series available
generating an asymptotic result would be
useful thing to do and
this one but then it would have
different output structure it wouldn't
be a serious data so then then I'm
saying I'm saying well okay fair enough
then then I'm saying generate what it's
generating now probably unless you think
that there's unless you think you can
improve it I mean see this old thing
does this old thing
yeah the the old thing never contains
anything other than a power is that
correct I think so so I think you guys
need to explore that a bit because I
think that the assumed the old thing
never contains anything more than a
power it does raise the question of
whether it could be generalized for the
Oh thing although you say the math just
isn't there yet to be able to do that
for general because you can't deal with
these different scales and order them
correctly and so on that's right okay
busy you don't have that there's too
heavy I mean first of all the arithmetic
operations work for power series and so
does the two big things the inverse
function and function composition those
were that those are the heavy duty
things that make do they work for
asymptotic series as well or not no they
don't generally work okay so for scale
sadder than that okay so let me just
understand that so in the case so I can
see that inversion might get really
hairy
yeah but the
function composition are more or less
the same okay fine all right so listen
this is my suggestion okay let's figure
out how to clip the wings of series a
bit by generating some messages saying
I'm producing something but it isn't
really very useful right use that some
tot ik if you want something useful here
to lead people towards asymptotic
meanwhile there is no good reason series
can't deal with within the domain of
things that do have power series deal
with things like inactive integrals and
I suggested it does right okay so that's
my initial suggestion let's take another
look at this with that with that in mind
of you know how do these functions
dovetail with each other it's perfectly
reasonable for series you know it's just
like okay you've got you know certain
linear problems that have you know
endlessly more capability than the
nonlinear case right I mean like like
you know root objects can do a lot more
than some bizarre transcendental root
can do that's a bad example but um you
know oh I don't know let's say rational
numbers we can clue you more with
rational numbers than we can with
arbitrarily complicated root objects so
similarly here it's perfectly reasonable
to provide people with the series that
in the domain where you can use power
series which is all kinds of plenty of
things in engineering and elsewhere you
know it'll sing and dance and do lots of
great things sure but but we need to
make sure that whatever it can do
whatever like Laplace transform there's
no reason a series can't deal with an
inactive Laplace transform unless the
Laplace transform doesn't you know come
out in terms of a series but now it's
perfectly reasonable to say okay there's
a larger class of higher wire act things
which are the asymptotic series as in
glottic expansions and I mean it took a
clear-cut serious develops is also an
asymptotic series it's just that the
class of such things is richer we needed
to just Express
well it's not really an asymptotic
series it's a the cities and what's that
you mean in what sense is an asymptotic
series it is any power scale you know
near wherever the point it is it's
asymptotically okay fair enough fair
enough fair enough in that sense but
it's also it's also a special thing just
like a linear problem it's a special
thing that's true the power series yeah
we've got a lot of apparatus for dealing
with power series which cannot be
generalized to arbitrary asymptotic
series that's right and some other
things that can be so that's there's
nothing wrong with that that's not
embarrassing no functions have to duke
it out in a duel etc right um so with
that in mind let's take a look at what
you have here okay so so I'm gonna make
a bunch of suggestions here okay so
first of all let's figure out how to
make series generate a message in these
cases second of all let's make sure
asymptotic can deal with unevaluated
inactive functions also this syntax of X
goes to X 0 I kind of think we should
support that in series also um and AH
now you've got a you've got a thing here
that says asymptotic terms yes that
controls
friendo what it controls I can see that
like its equivalent to having yes I'm
not sure I'm that keen on that name I
see is there an analog of that name
elsewhere in some domes that's not its
happiest that's not that was a kind of a
hacky option yeah I'm not saying that's
a good name we could chain that for sure
um okay
the point here I'm I'm thinking is if we
could get a name here that could be
reused in series and we could support
the X ro 0 which I would like anyway
because I think it's it's you know it
um it goes with limit much better that's
their idea exactly so kind of stratas
about reading those two right I mean if
what we could do is to say something
like um look I mean you know here's what
I would say I mean I would say I would
call it like expansion terms banchon
order is expansion order right or
expansion terms this is a problem when
you're in the class of powers here is
then often people want to think in terms
of order so I mean if we call it I don't
know we haven't gone with it we've
called it approximations we haven't
called them expansions okay well and we
shouldn't do it here um I mean what
we've the analog of this for you know
it's things like precision goal and so
on right is there is the yes ah I mean
it's a little weird and probably not
good but terms go because you might not
even get that many terms that's an
interesting idea actually
and that looks like kind of more honest
if you like are there we are saying that
that's what you really want but we may
not be we'll give it to you yeah I
definitely like terms goal as as such
without more decoration bother is too
weird but it's at roughly what would
what happens in practice that we search
for them but you may not find them right
I think that's what we should we should
go in that direction but now what's the
right name is it do we want to call it
terms
I mean the problem is difficult
asymptotic terms go as you as you say
well how bad would that be for series
record series terms or would that not be
right faster product than I mean I think
series is kind of what you every term in
some sense for common users you know I
don't know Roger I mean well it is an
asymptotic series yes I think all these
please don't pull it down we call it a
power series typically because that's
what we do want to call it because it's
a um now what about okay so here's a
question series all the things like
series coefficient to those work in any
way with asymptotic or not they evoke a
discrete as they look a discrete
asymptotic which is a discrete version
let me take a look at that in a second
okay so what that means you know and
this is this is one important case we
wanted to get to but I think you guys
both talk past each other so let me
explain
serious coefficient is the same as
inverse z-transform right oh that's true
yeah okay
so just the inverse of a generating
function mm-hmm now when you do so one
way that you can yeah when you analyze
algorithms for instance you often get a
generating function and you want to get
a serious antartic series coefficient is
that tells you - you've got a complexity
it was an important case to get so yes
you can use discrete asymptotic of a
series coefficient of something that
doesn't evaluate where you have it
inactive and it will compute it using
asymptotic methods okay you're showing
an example here yes yes that's from a
book by alternating functions by the
wolf there's a standard thing which you
could do for so long and all we can
visualize are we kind of saw that the
company has a student of Wolf's I seem
to remember somebody in our orbit I
remember vaguely recall that - I can't
remember yeah um okay so that is and so
now if I were to say series of series
coefficient
there's no discreet support basically
over there it's a discrete variable yeah
it doesn't understand discrete variable
cider I say so we do need two discrete
asymptotic for shell the closet it's
baby baby oh you guys jump okay
is your saying that
so for our serious discrete asymptotic
of prime of K as K goes to infinity will
give you something do with that
particular example right now okay sorry
about that I don't know what happened
but in the last few days did somebody
with it so I don't know what happened
but something changed somehow okay but
this should give you you can do
partitions P if you like sorry about
that I apologize it is something happen
and I'd not in my control really
that's very cool let me just understand
this for a second what I'm seeing it
this is very very cool yeah we're
starting to get a lot of asymptotics for
a discrete sequence it's number theory
yeah that's extremely impressive
analysis so if you've done a survey of
all of them and trying to get the whole
lots of Charles's help but I'm not real
expert in this area no that wouldn't
probably will not get you very far
because it's going to try other method
but we only have I mean we only have the
leading term because the zoning so
that's why I've been insisting to get
those you know knowing how much we have
and hopefully show you that's correct I
know I'm sure it's correct too but I'm
annoyed that I didn't get that report
back yeah okay so hold on okay
magnificent so this
like for example if I do percent 34
slash dot end goes to I don't know 200
or something yeah I didn't do it end of
that and that should may need to go to
high position over there well I don't
think so so now I say partitions P 200
and then n of that yeah I know sorry
it's okay
then it softened it very cool Ramanujam
was the proud no doubt um okay okay I
understand so let me let me just try and
ingest what you're telling me here so in
a in a series the variable might be like
close to zero for example and then it
better be a continuous variable so to
speak a real variable at infinity it
could either be a variable that's going
to infinity like a real number or it
could be going there sort of in steps as
an integer
exactly okay so in principle series
could take in the case where you're
expanding about infinity it could in
principle I'm not suggesting it does
because I suspect that the mathematics
is totally different take essentially a
domain in other words what we're saying
here so asymptotic so okay so I'm just
so discrete asymptotic is analogous to
well okay discrete limit the speed limit
yes so I mean in this case here so if I
would say for this one um thing here but
if I would say for this one yeah so the
thing is that if a limit exists for a
continuous thing it exists for the
discrete thing but it can exist for the
discrete thing without it existing for
the continuous thing so it can exist yes
absolutely right I understand why didn't
that work
because that's that's n goes to infinity
that should just be zero
right yes
why didn't that work I'm not sure I
could look at that I mean we do try and
support these operators that discreetly
I don't know but this particular one I
can check yeah okay fine all right so
now series coefficient also works when
applied to a series output right yes if
it's within you know because there
I mean if it's because their series did
when you guys see yeah but it's finite
it's like a finite list right so it
needs to okay so this documentation is
complete nonsense I mean that first
thing I suppose is correct you think
they're all correct submit misleading we
should probably move that one down to
the end or something because the other
is a much more so I mean this does two
things then yes cuz it so here I can
just say n is 8 for example yeah okay um
okay which is then equivalent to series
coefficient of sine X that's very weird
X 0 9 so it's the terminal object in
other words this is
hmm okay so it's the series of order n
but now this series coefficient in here
can this it this cannot be an asymptotic
thing this has to be a power series for
this to make any sense lightness
that's how serious coefficient is
defined in right because otherwise
there's no way you could ask for the nth
one right right right
it implicitly assumes a power series
yeah absolutely
okay okay I I'm getting this I mean this
is this is pretty reasonable I mean that
we can we can explain this these
functions don't have to be embarrassed
about each other makes it makes sense um
I don't think that they are I mean I
don't know I understand that but we have
to do things like as I said for the
fourth time here you know making sure
that an active of integrate works in
series and so on yes I made a note of
that okay all right fine so discrete
asymptotic it's a bit of a weird word
I'm a little concerned about the term
asymptotic I mean as topics you know
some thought it would be good to I mean
that we're fine with that but this is
wrong that first uses measures is wrong
it isn't a series approximation it's
just an asymptotic approximation for
exper at X goes to X 0 that's true you
could skip the serious bit leave a skip
the series we didn't know exactly what
that's of V agrees that I mean given
that asymptotic well I don't know that I
actually should change this um do you
want me to or not um
it's fine it means there Roger wait yeah
I think that's that's correct actually I
mean there's more detail explanation
below in the notes okay fine I mean okay
why don't I let you change it rather
than me right
gives an asymptotic approximation to
exper at you know at the point X goes to
X zero okay alright okay so now okay and
so then what we're gonna do then is
we're gonna say series terms no just you
understand one uh term at a point I have
here yeah it's not explicitly in these
notes so we have a limit function that
says limit X / comma X goes to X zero
and then there's all kinds of
multivariate extensions yep we can only
solve two cases but we need a third so
we can solve the case where you approach
that point from any direction in the
domain you know if it's univariate it's
in the complex domain from any possible
direction yes or we can approach it just
along a line array that's the direction
that's the old direction you know thing
and it works the same way multivariate
either we can approach it through any
direction in a complex ball or real ball
or along a line but as you know for
special functions what happens is that a
we have a well-defined limit in a sector
you know so it's a it's not a full ball
and it's much bigger than just array
so there should be a constrained limit
effectively I understand where we need a
cone you know typical thing and we need
a better cone language and so on
you know sector and cone like well and
you and there's no guarantee that the
thing doesn't look like a potato or
something the region of where something
is true well that's that's true but you
know the question is should we be able
to give that in and right now there is a
particular hang-up with assumptions
can't apply two variables only two
parameters and maybe we can overcome
that in case we have something good
let's review the the bigger class of
things so another one is contour
integrals where you have to specify the
contour well this is complicated thing
for other reasons and we are working on
that now for an internal project but
it's still very far from a
user-specified language because what
people don't usually want used to
specify the detail parameterize contour
and a we wouldn't want them to anyway
because that's not very usable in
practice except for I mean they're named
contours like I don't know the Bromwich
contour or something that's true there's
a bunch of named things but a typical
thing you want to do is to include
things or exclude things you know
exclude this pole or this singularity
exclude this branch cuts include this
singularity gems I'd say yes so that is
it so to cut the right level of symbolic
description that's actually gonna be
pretty productive there's a little bit
of work no I like that I mean that that
sort of set theoretic kind of version of
include exclude and so on right seems
useful and you know
because it also doesn't matter you know
if if certain features of the function
are I mean you know by Toshi's theorem
among other things right I mean it just
it doesn't matter where you are so it
only matters if you have these features
of the function in or out
exactly so that's them did more the
essence of the what people are trying to
use contry integration for it's a really
good point I mean it's almost like the
exclusions business in um in ordinary
and integrate right we have an
exclusions we certainly have that in yes
right and so in a sense this is this is
some kind of bizarre complex analog of
that story is that true statement yeah
it's it's a very similar but it needs to
be worked through in detail so it's
operationally effective both can be
implemented and effective from a user
perspective yeah I mean also they're
gonna be named things like saying you
know ignore you know go outside all the
poles of this function even if you don't
yet know what the poles are yeah things
like that um that's the more kind of a
language I think is needed for a
productive then if you do specified
today you can specify the detail contour
and by the way if you specified a
contour for a symbolic integrate today
it will actually as of 12-1 start using
internal contour integration where
because we understand all the
singularities of our the experts what do
you mean who starts by the content with
a parametrized thing in the complex
plane oh yeah so it can only deal with
you know if you in the X goes from X min
to x max that can be a list of points so
it's basically polygonal path yes okay
so it's just the only unless you give a
parametrization in which case it looks
like an ordinary integral it's just a
polygonal contour path that we can
support today but if you do that it will
actually try to use cautious theorem
because we have very efficient ways to
get to all the singularities and for if
I if I have a real integral you know
integral from minus infinity to infinity
I could say minus infinity i infinity
it's not right while I don't but you
could try it but I don't know it's
usually something special with
infinities that's okay but I mean if I
say something like what's a good example
I'm like like a Hilbert transform you
type thing
I don't really know things right but um
- infinite a high infinity that's not a
closed contour error first of all
it needs to be closed for cautious
theorem to apply my understand okay so
then I would go so that so that will
look very weird and here because it will
be something which appears to be going
back to nothing yeah I mean God knows
what's exceptions there are four
infinities I don't know in how Adam has
implemented this right now I mean
they're impressive cases that do work
and as I said the future of those such a
function is is more elaborate look at
that yeah what is it good
pretty cool I think this probe worked
before right I'm not sure I think it
might have worked actually huh
but there are other impressive cases I
can't find one right way unless I go
look right okay but fine but I mean Adam
obviously has to work on the Infinity
case because this is I mean that's a
pretty usable an interesting thing being
able to do that I mean there are cases
clearly in which it doesn't have to
close the contour you know if the
function is symmetric and things like
this in which it can do all kinds of
things to essentially use Kashi's
theorem without having the contour
explicitly closed yeah they're a bunch
of things they're you know an implicit
close close of this nature or daffy
nature in that literature I understand
okay let's come back to asymptotics okay
disk the word asymptotic and discrete
asymptotic so you're saying discrete
asymptotic is reminiscent of other you
know discrete something rather fun well
since we can't say sequence we've been
forbidden to say sequence for sequences
so we call them discrete functions you
have forbidden us well because we're
using the sequence for something else
well it just means it just means a list
without list header I mean it's
something in the low-level language no
no no no no no no Roger so we have to
use to see no no no there are things
like sequence position and so on which
is something completely different right
but anyways in the mathematical part of
the system we don't call sequences
sequences yes you can't okay according
to that design rule so
the thing that bothers me is the term
asymptotic is sort of the wrong part of
speech it's an adjective and only the
only River draw us is that asymptotic of
integrate should give you asymptotic
integrate which may not be a good reason
from your point of view no so asymptotic
is fine too if you think that's better
no asymptotic plural is awful that
suggests you're gonna get a report
exactly yeah okay so an asymptotic
series would make sense if it wasn't for
the fact that you have a common case
which is the one term case all right
asymptotic can be and so the description
of discreet asymptotic is it's the
asymptotic approximation to the discreet
what is the description here I just
don't like discrete asymptotic very much
what are you doing why are you writing
it with an explicit infinity here why
are you not writing it with an X zero no
I mean the only interesting place for a
sequence is infinity finite point well
why then are we not just allowing it to
be Expo comma n what about minus
infinity yeah minus infinity should work
- we could do that yeah it's stupid I
mean it come on the syntax where you say
n arrow infinity and the arrow infinity
doesn't matter it's clearly wrong right
okay so what we need to do here could
you possibly stop grinding a piece of
paper on your desk or whatever you're
doing there um okay
this doesn't make sense right I mean so
if I say an arrow 10 and you can only
approach it over the integers
yeah it's pretty stupid I agree so an n
ro zero is not interesting I mean
basically for the case of ordinary
asymptotic zero and infinity are both
interesting and and one is interesting
too if you've got a bunch of X minus 1
terms so now at any point is interesting
for ordinary over continuous domain any
point is interesting ok so what are the
other what are the other things that's
like discrete limit does it have the
same issue of the Infinity is
interesting yes or minus infinity
okay so I strongly think we should
support discreet limit f of K what the
hell is that
FK doing here we don't do it that way we
don't write it like that we write it as
x per right fight cuz it isn't always an
F of K I mean we could have written it
that way but we don't write as in this
example shows but I don't see why you
shouldn't then support discrete limit x
per comma K with the arrow infinity
elided see what I'm saying
not document it no I would document that
I don't see why you wouldn't document it
gives the limit as it goes to
that's what you want that's what when
you're talking about discreet limits
that is what you want that is the story
that it's going to infinity right yeah
or minus infinity I know but you can if
you really want minus infinity you can
say an arrow minus infinity but if you
just say comma n let it be defaulting to
infinity
sure and similarly here I would give a
two argument form of that list and comma
m and I don't know why it's called M
because that's like super confusing I
mean you should call this this is really
a mess come on using K here use K here
use n for the order as you have in the
other things okay
make sense surrender yes yes yes
actually I see another problem here but
it's Futurist it's just too many uses of
n the N variable case uses n variables
Oh can't end that it's okay in this case
this future iced it's not now it's jump
right right right right yes I'm sure
that that was done differently in there
in the series case okay notwithstanding
all these design comments but that's
what these meetings are for this
functionality looks absolutely fantastic
thank you I do want to so I mean so a
bunch of famous theorems like the prime
number theorem presumably are
represented in this function Alice yes
it is yes you could have some sort of
prime by effects that you should get
back the asymptotic over there and there
you get the full series actually I
hopeful it's still working as I'm sure
with prime prime PI of X I guess yeah
BECs
I wish it didn't Rio de it like that
that's kind of a mess that's why I'm
saying that if we had a different output
wrapper that had maintained the partial
order then we can both typeset it better
and it would not yeah on the other hand
the disadvantage of that is then then
you've got the annoying thing of having
to do normal exactly exactly that's why
we haven't done it but it's I mean this
the typesetting a plus and times is
getting really annoying I agree with
look I suspect what we should do
I mean there's all kinds of stupid
things like the the the constants of
integration being wrong etc etc etc the
question really is to what extent can we
imagine breaking away from what you see
is the ordering you have see what I'm
saying if we could break away from that
we can imagine storing internally
information about what the ordering is
some advisory information about the
ordering I'm not sure I don't know if I
should say it is here but I think that
you know I'm gonna you know my launch is
a pretty serious initiative to make
formulas insightful I think that there
was a time when people were very proud
of giving something that has multi-page
output but has zero insights in it um
because you could but
think that that's pointless it we need
to have formatting that takes advantage
of we have the most serious formatting
system in assist in the business and we
can actually create insightful formulas
so that means that it's gonna do a lot
more work on typesetting going well I
mean look the thing we've been working
on independently as things like the code
folding formula folding type stuff sure
lighting pieces and so on right but this
is the analog thing for mathematical
formulas is they gonna survive and have
any meaning going forward they can have
to be insightful if it's gonna do dafuq
cares yeah but I mean in in um you know
I think the question there's a different
point of view insofar as publications
start to be interactive then you can do
very different things with formulas yeah
but that doesn't stop any it doesn't
change anything of what I said you can
but no but I understand drives actual
publications do exactly what I scribed
they do create insightful formulas they
do not publish machine code they put
effort into making them insightful so
they're it's very well developed but I I
still think a separate topic that the
you know plus or during discussion is
one that we probably should continue you
know I push it again a couple of times
with multivariate ordering and changing
that and things and I I think we should
continue that discussion because they
don't think it's optimal um I think we
can you know we can have some yeah can
we put that please
I guess Devon is the one taking notes
and so on here if um I mean it's not a
for tomorrow but it's a discussion I
want to try having again I mean I've
tried having it a couple of times each
time typically it I convinces me that
it's impossible to do anything but I'm
not I'm not firmly convinced um let's go
through we're not gonna agree on the
experimental icing right this moment but
I expect we can um let me just
take a look at what you have here so the
forms of these solutions are still
staying the same it's it's merely that
we have a lot more stuff that we're
doing is that correct well formed forms
might be changes I mean absolutely forms
might change over time as we get better
solvers higher quality forms absolutely
they will change there's no there's no
we nothing casing given solutions in
stone we cannot no no I have her agree
to that SLA right I understand that
point my issue is what is this showing
this is showing so this is a benchmark
that has 1461 PDEs and now you see sin
pi and maple and sage doesn't have any
PD support right okay and you see us
eleven three twelve o twelve one okay
that's good um okay well but there's
still
percenter we can't do that's right yes
and that's quite a large we have a
notebook with all those we are trying
our best on all worked us actually and
and what I mean for integrals the number
that we can't do is vastly vastly
smaller than that now now let's do
that's do that then another I don't want
to do it in a public forum I mean I can
but it's that's that's a big discussion
topic okay all right oh my gosh new
basic examples Wow
really yes what was wrong with what we
had before didn't exist uniformly there
were many missing so now we have a kind
of uniform pattern which no you need to
go to BES again you sorry because
they're not show up in the builds for
summary most of what they've done is to
include in so first of all it's a fairly
uniform template numerical evaluation
real plot complex plot and some
asymptotics and then much more detailed
handbook style things under scope and we
have complex plots just won't use it and
let people know that we've got this I
mean the point of a plot is to
understand the overall behavior of a
function that's the insight you want to
create in users minds and in some ways
asymptotic souls it creates an overall
understanding of the behavior of a
function okay this is not acceptable
stuff get rid of that [ __ ] don't put
that in our examples it's okay I connect
but unnecessary okay
I mean if if you need to do this right
no what are you trying to show here just
the point but I think it gets a cogniser
than the actual documentation why it's
not getting ionized that's code it'll be
right there please don't put stuff like
that in it's completely unnecessary
okay um some okay you know I mean first
of all these examples know the hell is
this
no get rid of it plot legend arrow
expressions come on you don't need all
of that stuff and also please don't use
that sign okay even this this was
released in 12 the scope examples okay
well they should be fixed okay I mean
you know you can probably deal with them
boy I really don't like this I really
don't like this I you know I don't like
having to define variables here a lot of
this stuff should probably be ionized it
probably isn't the actual documentation
you look at the whole look page I think
it should be done there so I only go to
for the basic examples a few days ago so
he is putting them in but are you saying
it was in 1200 or not it has a scope not
the basic do you understand different
sections we have in examples okay so
that's not ionized that's no nurse crap
right okay and I don't understand this
this is so stupid to do this that this
way so stupid to do something where you
you've got things going across multiple
lines you don't need to do it it's just
gonna make it so that when somebody copy
paste this example it will work right
right
do we really need that I mean do we
really need to have something we're okay
separate discussion please don't put
stuff like this in the exhaust cables
are nice and clean leave them nice and
clean don't have things where unless you
want to invent a mechanism which you can
certainly try and get the documentation
team to do where if you copy that line
you get that line as well but we're not
gonna be able to do that in standard
documentation because we're told it's
just because they're copy thing for the
web you're complaining now but example
group is an example group you evaluate
the example group you change whatever
you want it works fine it just hasn't
been made to work on the web yet well
that's an important case but I mean look
just make this look nicer I mean it in
in I don't know I mean like point size
large do we really need that do we
really need that and what about the fact
that you're supposed to use style
wrappers not these naked primitives
anymore do you know what I'm saying
yes okay why are we writing bad code and
putting it in our examples that's not
useful and look at all this junk
likewise
why isn't this a sole value why is this
a Slashdot part one what is all this
nonsense I thought we had don't we have
this thing sole value no we don't not
yet no well why not I mean we need that
because we don't we don't have it
because we don't okay
but we should have it because that's
what we won't we agree with that I mean
it's just no we won't you have four
twelve one because it just came up I
made a note of those no problem okay but
then this please do not use deprecated
forms of the syntax okay should be this
point if you're really gonna do it if
you really insist on having a red point
there and you can't get it to be read by
default then do that please sure
oh this is cool
hopefully lots of people are
successfully finishing the course are
they well that's not clear via court not
people who actually seem redundant work
but we need to have better analytics
from our or education initiative I don't
you know the analytics we get is what
they can get from Google and that just
doesn't tell us anything about how
students are transitioning through the
course that just melting the cloud this
course uses the cloud right it uses
whatever we have for Wolfram you yes it
uses the cloud or whatever no no but I
mean when people answer exercises
they're doing it in the cloud is that
correct yes for from you no no I
understand but I mean they're typing
code yes they just bring multiple-choice
most of time right now okay why aren't
we doing actual type an answer because I
didn't even know it would work be so
successful so now got someone who start
often probably January he may be
available for us but we didn't have a
clue that would go so well basically
honestly so if you now think that's
worth a while to do it fair enough I
mean you're able is the fantastic course
of that sense it's got nice exercise and
all that we aren't there yet right I
mean it wasn't exactly hard to make the
exercises via the scoring was hard but
the the exercises were not hard yeah you
do scoring for multiple choice which is
vastly easier yes and then that keeps
track off I mean people finish and they
feel good about it you know well I mean
okay so I mean you know that there's a
whole initiative coming with courseware
tools and so on which hopefully you will
be able to use yes will that improve the
tools that we have formatting
dramatically so how many people are
going to work on those tools or who is
going to work on them well we have a a
you know Rory and Sylvia are two people
who are gonna be involved you probably
don't know either of them right um I
think that the the real issue is how
much
heavy-lifting coding is going to be
involved versus how much basically just
restructuring when we've got both Kyle
Keane stuff and we've got you know he's
developed a lot of stuff that's that
some connection with this you know with
what he's put out from MIT and also the
CBM people have produced a lot of stuff
and both of those are sources and we'll
be using those and I you know it's
unclear how much its final assembly
versus how much it's heavy lifting
hopefully that will be found fairly soon
you know and and I mean the basic
strategies for how we present things
using form notebooks and so on I think
will work nicely
I mean look improvement on that side
both that makes it more efficient to
produce courses and makes for a richer
student experience or valuable yeah well
I think that you know so the other the
other thing is to said I really want
better analytics if we're gonna invest
more resources into it I want it's very
important that we find out back we have
to kind of stop investing in it right
hey listen I need to I need to go just
for a few minutes to some other meeting
and I know we have a meeting about graph
theory in a number theory a moment let
me let me just take five minutes to go
deal with something else and then I will
be back
um and we can work on graph theory
number theory okay okay but this is not
we should play a take we gotta take a
little bit more time and look through a
few more of these things um what does
that mean I'm not a meeting I think so
yeah okay so I'm flying out Friday just
so you know um and then I'm gonna be
back two weeks later so why don't we do
this
at a time when you can do it from Sweden
in the I can do that probably a week and
a half in but not the first week okay
well whatever I mean that it is what it
is I mean I think we've gotten a good
distance here most likely I know we've
probably combined the final review of
this with some other things and fit them
all in our hmm okay okay but the sole
value is the thing you're gonna work on
right D so value exists no I understand
small value is not in this review I
understand that I understand that yes
okay all right sounds good okay I will
see you and two folks on our livestream
we will be back for another episode in
just moments graphs and networks okay
and good work Devendra talk to you soon
thank you okay bye